eric lauer
his last start was against the
cincinnati reds
it had been 11 days between outings fly
ball into center field garcia
backing up he's got room at the track
and he's got it
and lauer is off and running tonight
kenta maeda he's looking for his 50th
career win that would be the eighth
japanese-born player to reach such a
mark
has got most of what milwaukee can offer
in terms of firepower in the first four
spots two down
fighting it over his last 17. three for
23 on the year noah sure lead he won't
be running here he stays put and the
three two are swinging a liner to left
near the corner and yelich doesn't see
it it's over his head
and finds the wall cenos going to make
third and tony diaz is going to send
them around
the throw to the plate and to know
diving head first he scores
on a cave rbi double and it's one
nothing twin
now there's a slice of sunshine right
now at miller park with the roof open
and an area out near the warning track
and left is the area and sun
and caves liner went into that area and
yelich never saw it is not wearing
sunglasses
he never saw the ball here's the rise
average down to 216.
and that's the left field and that's
down for a hit
looked like yellow had a hard time
seeing the
track of that line drive as well
two nothing twins as they get some
production from the bottom of the order
apolanco will try to make the brewers
pay for some outfield mistake
and that's into left center field down
for a head
arrives will score and it's three to
nothing
and also a little misplayed ball by
abisal
garcia turns into another run for the
twins
now nelson cruz and he's thinking big
here
three in two on two out and here's the
pitch of swinging a broken bat
liner into left center that's the base
hit garver scores polanco racing to
third crew stops at first
and it's a four-nothing twins lead here
in the second
so cruz with his 17th rbi regains the
team lead one better than rosario
and the twins have brought eight to the
plate and scored four and hopefully not
done now that ball gets by
the catcher narvaez and coming in from
third is
polanco and it's five to nothing snow
hitting about 25 struggling
striking out an awful lot
a long blast to left field
welcome to slide i have no idea where
that landed
[Applause]
well a towering home run to left field
he's been trying to do that for a while
this one he got into
i mean we don't even know where the ball
went absolute
100 maximum effort bat speed
and perfect contact angle that was just
as good right there
it must have come down because they've
already measured it at 442 feet
marvin gonzalez will bat
this right field corner with the runner
going should score
rosario will round third and head home
and gonzales tacks on another run here
in the fourth with an opposite field
double
[Applause]
it's kind of what we were hoping for
twins kind of having several innings
where they're applying pressure
it's a violent swing almost he he wants
to crush the baseball
and he hits it to right and a diving
catch in right field by j cave
fine play by cave to end the fourth
inning
buxton to bat and the bloop single his
last time up
everybody so far tonight has reached
base
and a line drive into left field yellich
back he'll look up
and go a one-handed home run
for byron buxton stay hot
it's his fourth home run on this road
trip
and eight to nothing he was fooled on
that and
just one handed it another 3-2 to cruz
[Applause]
oh he walked with the bases loaded so
we'll run batted in for cruz
at least two runs here in the fifth
grimmer fire retired the first two
batters he faced now five straight have
reached
and now six straight have reached three
in a row have walked
and another bases loaded walk
there's a high fly to right
gammel is there should score a run
polanco will trot home for the fourth
run of the inning
he's scored in every inning but the
first
full count now to buxton
[Applause]
deep to left center field what a great
at bat for buxton
he's got another home run that ball was
smoked
buxton with two tonight five on the year
but that was a
the cap off of a great at bat when he
fell behind early fouled some two strike
pitches
and then golfed one out of here
a little fly ball in the shallow right
center gamel lays out and
makes the catch all right great
effort in a blowout game beautiful play
by gammel
first at bat for uras
and he lines one into left field a base
hit
in the score sogard hiro right behind
him
luis urias with his first rbis as a
brewer
and the brewers are on the board in the
sixth inning
and the twins leave milwaukee with a
series win
it was a great game with kind of what
the doctor ordered for the twins tonight